HARISH KURAM: Hello, everyone.
Please welcome to
today's presentation
in the data analytics stream,
scaling data driven insights
across a complex
global organization
with Looker and BigQuery.
In today's
presentation, we would
like to cover Iron Mountain
business and technical drivers,
data analytics and
visualization architecture that
was established,
scalability principles that
were in play, GCP products
and services that were used,
Looker value proposition for
Iron Mountain, challenges
and recommendations made.
Before we get into
the details, we
would like to
introduce ourselves.
I'm Harish Kuram, principal
data architect at SpringML.
I was the project manager for
this Iron Mountain project.
I have around 25
years of experience
implementing and delivering
technology projects
across many large companies.
JARRETT GARCIA: Hi, my
name is Jarrett Garcia.
I'm the director of enterprise
platforms at Iron Mountain.
I've been with Iron
Mountain since December,
and I've been excited to
join the Iron Mountain
team to establish a
singular data platform.
HARISH KURAM: I would
like to give you
a quick introduction to the
Iron Mountain technical data
analytics project.
SpringML, in partnership
with Google PSO,
worked together for 10
weeks this past March
and April to successfully
deliver this project.
Iron Mountain provided the
program leadership and SMEs;
SpringML provided the sprint
planning, scrum management,
and implementation;
while Google PSO
provided the product assembly,
architecture, consultation,
and oversight.
I would now like to
hand it over to Jarrett
to speak about Iron
Mountain, the initiative that
led to this project,
and the current state.
Over to you, Jarrett.
JARRETT GARCIA: Thanks, Harish.
So this is the typical who
is Iron Mountain slide.
We're a global leader for
storage and information
management services,
we're in 50 countries,
and we service a ton of clients.
I'm not going to spend
a lot of time here.
Hopefully you've
heard of us and we
can move on to the next slide.
So today, what we
wanted to talk about
is the global enterprise,
the data platform
where what we're trying to
solve is a localization problem
that Iron Mountain has had.
So we have a lot of
different systems,
a lot of different countries
that we're working with,
and each system in
each country has
their own way of doing things.
It tends to lead to
a lot of repetition
as well as a lot
of customization.
It also gives our
executive team a lot
of headaches because we're
not able to necessarily look
at the company holistically.
So when we want
to see a footprint
for a particular client, it
can take several weeks for us
to be able to
gather all that data
and then be able to present that
information back to our client.
The goal of the
global data platform
is to be able to
centralize all of this.
The project that we
began with Google
and with SpringML was geared
to get this kicked off.
What we wanted to do is to take
some of our operational systems
and land everything into
a central data platform.
We also then wanted to write a
bunch of different dashboards
and develop insights that
would enable our leadership
to have a global viewpoint.
Moving on.
So there were three main things
as we talk about our master
data initiative.
One is the technology.
So we're a Google company.
We love working with Google.
We love GCP.
We felt that BigQuery was
the right platform for us.
BigQuery has a lot of
benefits, and Harish
is going to go over some
of those later on today.
But as a platform, being
able to pull everything
in to a central area and then
be able to utilize BigQuery
and all the things
that come with it
really is going to help
speed up that process.
The other thing that we
had to consider as well
is a governance policy.
So what we wanted to do is to
start to set up a data steward
model where we can formalize
our data governance practices.
So our idea here is
to democratize data
and to make it readily available
to all Iron Mountain employees.
But we do have to consider
specific things from a data
protection standpoint.
And then the other
part of this is
it's a big cultural
change for us, as well.
So the company wasn't
used to thinking this way.
So what we wanted
to do is to start
to show the entire company
that this type of thinking
and efforts can happen
quickly and pretty seamlessly.
We adopted an agile
mindset, and we
were able to start
to collect data
from different countries and
different operational systems
and start to land
it into the cloud.
And then as well, we partnered
with SpringML with Looker
and with Google in order to
build out those dashboards.
Moving on.
So I'm going to jump
a little bit ahead.
Harish is going to go through
all the details about how
we got to the end state.
But to give you a preview,
we were extremely successful
in the project.
We have today, based off
the success of this project,
we have 11 different systems
feeding our enterprise data
platform.
We have data from 56
different countries
flowing into the platform.
And for us, five terabytes is--
it's a good start.
We've only been up and
running for about six months,
so we're very happy with the
progress that we're making.
The monstrosity that you see on
the right is kind of a picture
that we have.
We're servicing different
use cases, as well.
So we're helping the business
from the records management
side, from the data
management side.
We're working with our
colleagues in infrastructure,
within project
management and HR,
to be able to give them
a lot more capabilities
than we've had in the past.
So with that, I'm going
to go ahead and hand it
over back to Harish.
HARISH KURAM: Thanks, Jarrett.
Before I delve in
deeper, I would
like to spend a minute or
two talking about SpringML.
We are a premium
Google Cloud Partner,
and we have delivered
over 200 plus cloud data
analytics and visualization
implementations.
We have four main capabilities
on the Google Cloud
stream of our business,
machine learning
and artificial intelligence,
cloud migrations, data
analytics and visualization,
and application development.
As a Google Cloud Partner,
we have achieved credentials
for four specializations, data
analytics, machine learning,
marketing analytics, and
application development.
Now I would like to delve deeper
into the Iron Mountain story.
I want to talk about
Iron Mountain's
business and technical drivers
for this and future projects.
Global operations
has a requirement
to realize cost savings in
record center operations.
There's a need for
productivity monitoring
in record centers across
the Iron Mountain footprint.
There is a need for consistency
in building and activity
definitions across countries
and operational systems.
There is a need for visibility
into facility or building level
information.
There's a lack of clear
insight for leaders
across multiple sites,
regions, and countries
that needs to be addressed.
There are mostly file-based
processes with challenges
related to file transfers.
There is a monolithic
data source scape
with challenges
related to reference
data definition for districts,
buildings, and activities.
There are time
consuming manual checks
with reference data
provided by business.
The reports are defined in
crystal reports provision
through business objects.
There is a need to
standardize reporting tools.
Now I would like to talk
about the architecture
of the solution we designed.
Some important features to note,
an on-premise virtual machine
to upload the data extracts
from multiple data sources
to Google Cloud Storage; file
upload event-based invocation
of Google Cloud
Composer DAG; upload
of data to BigQuery staging
tables orchestrated by DAG;
invocation of SQL
transformations
and merging of data orchestrated
by DAG into BigQuery
and reporting data set;
and finally, RCO reporting
dashboard that we built
on Looker which I'll
present on the later slide.
The relevant
scalability principles
in play for this
engagement are BigQuery,
a highly scalable
serverless data warehouse
setup with on-demand
usage and growth;
recommendation for automatic
scaling of Composer worker
nodes based on usage metrics;
and finally, an event
driven ingestion pattern
we've built with discussion
around moving to message
driven Cloud Pub/Sub in future.
With that, I would like now to
talk about the key TCP products
and services we implemented
on this project.
Google Cloud Composer for
workflow orchestration
that included processing and
loading files into tables
and running secret
transformations and mulch
queries.
BigQuery for loading, coding,
and analyzing large amounts
of data cost effectively.
Google Storage for staging
and archiving of file
extracts in CSV
formats, facilitating
future retrieval if necessary.
Google Operations or
Stackdriver for logging,
monitoring, and
alerting activities
of the ingestion pipeline.
And finally,
delivering insights,
reports, and dashboards
using Looker.
I would like to spend a few
minutes talking about business
intelligence platform,
Looker, and how
it benefited Iron Mountain.
Implementing Looker
helped us quickly
deliver insights and enable
real time analytics in a matter
of two to three weeks.
It helped us implement
governance and data integrity
by limiting table
access, data access,
masking specific
columns, and auditing.
Having the self-service feature
enable the business analysts
to ask new questions about the
data that is readily available,
and to troubleshoot
problematic indicators
with Iron Mountain operations.
And most importantly, Looker
leverages the GCP investment
by Iron Mountain.
It basically leverages
BigQuery natively
to perform all the queries.
What I'm now presenting is
the record center operations
dashboard that we developed
for Iron Mountain.
Some of the insights
the dashboard enables
are the ability to investigate
dip in achievement percentage
by drilling to specific
country, and district,
and down to the warehouse;
collaborate with country
managers to identify
specific bottlenecks
and take specific actions
to bolster the workforce
or take corrective actions
within the same day;
ability to explore the data
and ask additional questions,
especially why some buildings
are reporting high overtime
hours, for example;
set up alerts
when achievement thresholds
are not met so quick action can
be initiated.
Some of the challenges we
found and the recommendations
we were able to
provide are agreeing
upon data formats, business
logic, and structure
ahead of time to minimize
re-engineering, continue
to develop a diverse culture
for maximum scalability
and portability by leveraging
terraform for automated
deployments, and building a
CICD pipeline for efficient code
deployments.
Data cleansing is
best done upstream,
near the source of the
data, to minimize complexity
in coding logic.
Review architectural decisions
constantly and optimize
to implement the right fit.
For example, Cloud
Dataflow was determined
to be an overkill for the
simple transformations.
We switched to using BQ Load,
as there were minimal or no SQL
transformations, or the parallel
processing wasn't needed.
Identified growth opportunities.
We recommended improved
security monitoring,
firewall logs, alerts, and
so on, fault resolution,
and performance management
for future projects.
And finally, I would
like to close out
with the project outcomes
we were able to achieve.
We completed proof of
concept to ingest data
from Iron Mountain systems to
BigQuery for data analysis.
We enabled enterprise data
warehouse modernization
and reporting through
data democratization.
Enabled near real-time
handling of data ingestion
and on-demand visualization.
Helped reduce different tools
being used at Iron Mountain
to reduce copying of data sets.
Enabled iron
mountain for success
by beginning to
create a unified GCP
standard across
the organization,
and established an
infrastructure baseline
for future data ingestion
and visualization projects.
This concludes our presentation.
JARRETT GARCIA: Thank you.
HARISH KURAM: Thanks, everyone.